[Music]  [Music]  hello  michael  what have you done i was trying to help  people  but the cure  it's a curse  my cool  i have powers that can only be described  as superhumans  but there's a cost  now a face of choice it's a hunt  and consume blood  or die  we all have monsters within us  it's up to us to control it  what if i can't  you've been given a gift  not exactly  time to let go of what you used to be  discover who you're meant to be  all our lives we've lived with death  why shouldn't they know what it feels  like for a change  just accept who you are  the bad guy  more bs  holy water really  yeah you ever see lost boys story of my  life  a new marvel legend arrives exclusively  in movie theaters april 1st  [Music]  you